fuir licite chance qu à la faveur d'une
accalmie beaucoup sont déjà partis mais
avec les dernières nouvelles de
severodonezk les candidats au départ se
pressent à ce point de ralliement
aujourd'hui peu importe la destination
nous allons à denis propre aveu grade ou
qui nous amène vous voyez ce qui se
passe ici un missile est tombé dans mon
jardin tout a été détruit là tout est
tombé en morceaux roues et une heure
soit
chacun redoute la chute de severodonetsk
à quelques kilomètres d'ici les russes
pourraient alors encerclé les sites
chance
les autorités ukrainiennes tente tant
bien que mal de poursuivre les
évacuations
sont déçus tch ce n'est pas une énorme
évacuation d'une seule fois en sec mais
nous revenons chercher les gens fur et à
mesure que la situation s'aggrave une
partie du problème et de rassembler les
gens de toute la ville en un seul
endroit de location
difficile d'exfiltrer les derniers
civils dans cette localité où chacun
tente d'échapper aux bombardements
quotidiens
natalia nous emmène dans cette cave où
elle vit depuis bientôt quatre mois une
obscurité quasi totale
assis sur son lit à galina sa voisine
qui n'osent plus sortir des habitants
terrorisés
d'abord la guerre doit s'arrêter après
on verra sion par où passent là c'est
impossible d'y penser quand il ya des
bombardements comme ça tout le temps
aucune solution de nous vient à l'esprit
gemini kaki
un danger omniprésent dans la région ici
à barr mouthe à 50 km de lucy jones qu
un jour de marché presque ordinaire mais
où l'on se presse car de nombreux
magasins ont baissé le rideau mais là
encore la guerre sera là